Thanksgiving is different now
it's an old thing it's as old as America
and older than that George Washington
did a Thanksgiving Proclamation
Lincoln did a famous one 100 years later
I
traditionally it descends from the
Harvest Festival which is a seasonal
thing
so you spend the summer
getting in the crops praying for rain or
less rain it's never the farmers think
it's never the right amount of rain
and then you have the hectic thing of
getting the crops in which is night and
day labor and exhausting and then you've
got the crops and that's something to
celebrate
[Music]
life doesn't work that way anymore
it isn't seasonal
in the same way
so I think we have to make an effort to
make it seasonal
and there's many ways to do that the
college is actually in the business of
recalling things that are Beyond Time
things that are not just seasonal things
that are Eternal because you know at the
end of the season Thanksgiving is when
you think about
gratitude to the Eternal for the fact
that you've got food to eat
and for the chance to do the labor to
produce it
we can get the cooperation from nature
that it takes to produce it
and we're grateful for that and there's
a natural time to stop and be grateful I
think music is a great and powerful way
to go about that
music is a big thing here I sit in her
here in our Chapel it's being prepared
right now for a Christmas video that
you'll have access to pretty soon
by our new Sacred Music choir I think
you're going to see that they're
wonderful
what is the music that they sing
it's about the Eternal and music has an
unusual power to transport
and Plato's Republicans along with
gymnastic which is things you do to your
body to make it better it is the most
powerful of two powerful things
[Music]
music in political probably concludes
literature and poetry and all forms of
art that can affect the mind and the
senses and the emotions
and so uh music is very important
this morning I started listening to one
of my favorite pieces of music foray's
requiem
it's a 35 minutes long it's very
beautiful
the third movement is called Sanctus and
that comes from sacred and that word
sacred has meant the same thing in Latin
and all the other languages where it
appears it means touching they're
connected to the Divine the holiday
season which begins includes
Thanksgiving and runs through the
wonderful thing of Christmas
is a great time to celebrate the eternal
we have to remember to stop and do that
because
if we don't remember the Eternal our
temporal work our work in time won't be
meaningful or well directed our colleges
in the business of remembering the
sublime
because that is the end of life and the
only Guide to Life that will work
in this troubled time and it's very
troubled I worry about these times a
great deal
and then I remember the Sanctus and I
remember that sooner or later all will
be well
Happy Thanksgiving